Olá tudo bem com vocês Como vocês estão
Boa noite a
todos seja bem-vindos a mais uma
live vocês estão me escutando bem tão
me ouvindo me
vendo bem vamos começar respondendo as
dúvidas tá deixa eu dividir a tela aqui
com vocês
[Música]
uma pessoa saudável sem mutações do gnmt
hfr com níveis quadros de vitaminas em
uma dieta rica em
miina pode elevar os níveis de
homocisteína qual é a quantidade máxima
de área de metionina que deve ser
ingerida isso é muito complexo de
responder tá o o ciclo de metilação tem
vários pontos né Um Ciclo complexo então
tem gente que vai tomar metionina e vai
aumentar Mía e tem gente que não vai
aumentar Mía tá isso é muito variável
Qual é a quantidade máxima de área de
meina também vai variar tá eu
sugiro utilizar o s adenosil meina o Sam
não usar meina normal mas se você tiver
Boa Saúde você pode ingerir 500 mg 1 g
por dia sem
problemas de acordo com o protocolo
kofman a pirodo Amina que é o vitâmero
da vitamina B6 tem propriedades
antiglicantes essa fma de vitamina BC
poderia em tese diminuir a hemoglobina
clicada não eh ela não diminui a
hemoglobina clicada o que ela faz
é agir né como agente antiglicante tá
antiglicante ele não deixa a glicose
caramelizar as proteínas do sangue
tá
então sim na verdade a resposta para
essa pergunta é sim ela poderia diminuir
a hemoglobina glicada porque ela vai
diminuir a glicação de todas as
proteínas inclusive hemoglobina glicada
tá então sim a resposta é sim eu acho
que não tem ninguém ao vivo não me
assistindo tem Deixa eu perguntar aqui
no grupo
Doutor foi citado na Live de 3 de
setembro um possível benefício efeito
benéfico na da Ivete na Diabetes qual
seria esse efeito de reduzir os níveis
glicos do sangue Existe alguma dose de
ingestão diária para obter esse efeito
então Eh o difícil vai ser o
acompanhamento médico né porque Boa
noite TAM miquinha porque vai ser poucos
médicos que vão aceitar que vocêa
né mas a dose que tá sendo utilizada
mais comum é um comprimido A cada 30 kg
tá é a dose mais comum a gente não sabe
exatamente qual que é a dose que seria
ideal para controle do diabetes ainda
essa é uma informação muito nova a gente
só tem isso em estudos em rato e Estudos
em vitro também
tá a respeit da i prenção oncológica
acompanhando alguns grupos de uso of
Label e vejo consumos diários entre 12 e
24 MG ao
dia protocolo Dr c e para o tratamento
um regime de até 1 MG 1,5 MG kil peso
corporal em um dia e com folg de 3 a 7
dias protocolo PS Dr
CF no evento que o seu doutor participou
foi citado algum protocolo oncológico
não não foi quer dizer na na verdade
pode ter sido eu não assisti todas as
aulas tá Lucia quer mesmo assistir uma
uma aula o curso dela de pré-congresso
mas eu não vi a apresentação dela do
congresso eles não liberaram onine ainda
eles fizerão fazendo algum tipo de
ajuste lá depois então posso voltando
esse assunto com vocês boa noite
Fernando Ok então esse de 1 a 2 m kg
dia é para câncer tá essa dose alta é só
para câncer
mas isso isso deve sido falado no
Congresso mas eu não vi todas as aulas
do congresso
ainda só um minutinho pessoal vou pegar
uma água aqui para mim porque a garganta
tá meio
esquisita Quais exames relativos a
homônios devem ser realizados em homens
69 anos e quais os valores
ideais depende do laboratório depende do
hormônio é uma pergunta muito aberta
essa viu
não vai dar para responder não tem 10
kits de hormônio no
mercado e são pelo menos uns cinco
hormônios então fica difícil de
responder isso para você assim na lata
Tá Quais exames relativos hormônios Dev
ser realizados em mulher 62 anos e quais
os valores e estrona
estradiol
testosterona total e livre né shbg LH
FSH progesterona tá valores ideais de
novo depende do laboratório tá tem que
ficar entre terceiro e quarto quartil
qual melhor forma de suplementar Ferro
para quem tem ferritina baixa eu gosto
de prescrever o ferro na forma
eh existe um ferro no mercado que eu
fogen deixa eu falar para vocês aqui
Qual é a composição do fisiogen
esse fisiogen ele
tá venda livre em
farmácia
e é um ferro com a vitamina C Tá mas a
forma exata de ferro é pirofosfato
férrico
tá isso eu eu acho que a melhor forma de
você prescrever o ferro comprando na
fassa comum esse
fisiogen perguntei na Live passada
causas de cálculos biliares de pessoas
que nunca teve colesterol Total 200 pois
li algo referente à relação direta entre
colesterol Total acima de 200 e a
formação de cálculos biliares o se eu
concorda tem tem uma relação sim entre
um e outro existe essa relação e eu
falei as causas na Live passada a
proteína isolada da soja é segura para
tomar sim é
segura Qual que é a
relação do tnf Ala com ob
atividade física quando você tem
obesidade crônica você tá inflamado e a
tnf Alfa que é uma cador de inflamação
ele aumenta tá a atividade física também
pode ter um aumento eh temporário do tnf
Alfa mas ae vai cair rapidamente aí o
efeito final do exercício é
antiinflamatório né Que efeito de
hormese antitiroglobulina elevada T3 T4
TSH etc normais quais outros fatores que
devem ser avaliados para interpretar
essa
elevação antitiroglobulina aumentada é
do de rimoto tá tiol de rimoto tá e com
T3 T4 TSH normais é tiro de rimoto que
não deu hipotiroidismo ainda tá e tem
algum outro fator não patológico pode
elevar a antitiroglobulina como por
exemplo indicação Porã não musicação
porana não faz isso pode tomar zeolita à
noite perto de magnésio melatonina
Utrogestan não você pode tomar tipo uma
hora depois tá pode tomar à noite mas
não perto tem que dar um intervalo de
pelo menos uma
hora tenho feito a inalação todo dia com
própolis sem álcool do APS Flora para
desentupir o nariz 10 ml de soro quatro
Pingos de própolis mesmo sendo sem
álcool é
seguro mesmo s Endo sem álcool Por que
que o álcool betaria a segurança você tá
acompanhando ao
vivo porque não entendi essa dúvida
exatamente
não mas você é seguro sim você tá
falando de contaminação do própolis eu
não entendi bem sua dúvida Doutor é
possível alcalinizar o sangue não o
sangue não é alcalin o que você
alcaliniza é o organismo inteiro para
aumentar o p pro próprio organismo fazer
regulação
Tá mesmo que temporariamente elevando um
pouco o PH durante um certo período
visando o tratamento de doenças eu não
entendi qual que ser a lógica disso
porque se o o sangue a regulação do PH
do sangue o próprio organismo faz tá o
que você tem que fazer é dar os minerais
pro corpo para ele poder ele fazer essa
regulação caso poss poderia utilizar
bicarbonato de sódio pode você pode usar
bicarbonato de sódio Mas você não vai
pôr na veia né você vai tomar O
bicarbonato vi oral porque quanto tempo
o sangue permaneceria com pegar um pouco
mais alcalino isso não tem como dizer
antes do corpo realizar autorregulação
não é você não pode forçar o corpo a
ficar com sangue alcalino isso é não faz
sentido nenhum tá o corpo que faz essa
regulação seria possível medir essa
alcalinização temporária na urina sim
mas a urina é outro
compartimento é outro compartimento
vocês tem que entender que são vários
compartimentos no organismo no sangue
não deve mexer no PH do sangue tá o
próprio corpo ele faz essa regulação
quais os sintomas para se concluir que
se um HDL 72 em homem é disfuncional
exame de função hepática Gama GT TG TGP
fosase
alcalina tá bom são esses exames que
você vai fazer Boa noite Eliane taquinha
Fernando miram todos estão
acompanhando ouvi no YouTube que
mulheres com muito libido
são mulheres que TM muitos receptores
hormonais e na menopausa quase morre de
tantas dores pelo corpo todo quase morre
de tantas dores pelo corpo
todo na menopausa Por quê eu não posso
dar fogacho não dá dor no corpo todo
isso faz sentido Creio que não tá se
depois eu precisava ver esse vídeo que
você viu aí para ver se você não se
confundiu numa Live recente você
comentou sobre possibilidade
Inteligência Artificial influenciar na
longividade eu comentei isso não tô
lembrado mas sim é verdade você tem
alguma ideia de como a integração da
inteligência artificial com análise de
dados pode melhorar na eficácia dos
progas de rastreamento diagnóstico
precoce a ência artificial pode ser
usado por bem e pro mal Você sabem
disso ela pode ser utilizada como ela já
vem sendo utilizada para pesquisar novos
materiais tanto materiais da indústria
quanto biomateriais
ou nanomateriais para pra saúde tá
inclusive tá sendo utilizado a
inteligência artificial para descobrir
novos polipeptídeos para descobrir novas
conformações de
proteínas para poder revolucionar aí o
vários tratamentos médicos tá agora tua
pergunta específica como a integração da
inteligência artificial com análise de
dados que serja Big Data né pode
melhorar a eficácia dos progas de
rastreamento e diagnótico precoce
provavelmente vai surgir nos próximos
anos softwares que você vai alimentar
ele com muitas informações e a
inteligência artificial vai ajudar
nisso E aí você vai poder ter mais
exames mais
sofisticados e vai poder ter uma
medicina mais eh personalizada tá
conhece alguém no Brasil que já faz isso
faz isso o qu análise de dados para
melhorar efic o Programa de Rastreamento
e diagnóstico precoce não não
conheço fiz um vídeo deitado há 6
anos estava deitado essa coisa do Eliseu
eu não tô nem vendo o nome mas quer ver
É do Eliseu estava deitado e fazendo
terapia oxidativa em si mesmo você
explicou que retirava 100 ml de sangue
aplica terapia oxidativa aplica o ozônio
né é 100 ml de sangue 100 ml de ozônio
eh na bolsa e depois devolve o sangue tá
eh terapia e em seguida o sangue é
devolvido ao corpo isso esse autoterapia
com ozônio maior
falou também do princípio da
hormese aumenta as enzimas antioxidantes
sim falei disso esse tratamento chamado
PRP não isso aí é o auto hemoterapia
maior
tá aqui própolis sem álcool estou
fazendo alação todos os dias dúvida
acabou você disse que não ca dano caia
dano F falando inalação com própris é
isso
tá pode fazer não vejo problema
nenhum tem umas perguntas ao vivo
pessoal hoje eu fui mais rápido nas
perguntas aqui tá por causa do horário
mas vocês podem fazer as perguntas ao
vivo eu também separei o material aqui
para apresentar para vocês Deixa eu ver
se eu acho aqui eu tava com problemas no
meu computador tava lotado de coisa no
HD tive que dar limpada mais cedo aqui
foi um dos motivos que eu trazi a Live
hoje bem deixa eu achar aqui o documento
que eu eu quero apresentar para vocês
aqui
bem nós vamos falar da
trombose acho que não né bem vamos falar
sobre isso e a sua relação com a
moléstia você sabe do que eu tô falando
né Vamos explorar esse tema fascinante
entender como o nosso corpo reage a
infecções
graves como a causada pelo vírus
Ok então vamos desvendar como a trombose
que já conhecemos como a condição Grave
se conecta ao nosso sistema imune de
defesa
[Música]
e como é que as terapias experimentais
né
aquelas que foram feitas
durante a pandemia vocês sabem as
terapias gênicas de RN mensageiro entram
nesse cenário da
para isolar e destruir patógenos ou seja
agentes que causam mal a nós é o caso de
vírus e bactérias isso ajuda a limitar a
disseminação de infecções porém em
alguns casos pode sair de controle e
gerar complicações como obstrução de
vasos sanguíneos que pode comprometer o
funcionamento de órgãos a trombose que
ocorre dentro dos vasos é um mecanismo
Vital quando ele é bem coordenado bem
regulado mas poar patológico quando
exagerado então na moléstia esse
processo de coagulação desempenha um
papel crucial e como veremos a resposta
exagerada do sistema de defesa imune que
é desencadeada pelo vírus pode resultar
em problemas graves de coagulação Então
como que as terapias gênicas de RNA
Vocês estão entendendo que eu tô falando
como terapias gênicas de RNA tá
mensageiro estão relacionadas a isso as
terapias gênicas GNA mensageiro têm sido
utilizadas no contexto da imunização
contra a moléstia elas instruem o corpo
a produzir proteína s o que pode gerar
uma Resposta imune no entanto há
registros de que essa resposta pode em
alguns casos seja gerada resultando em
inflamações que favorecem o
desenvolvimento da
imunotrat essa resposta descontrolada
pode aumentar o risco de complicações
trombóticas o estudo dessa ligação entre
essas terapias experimentais e eventos
trombóticos TM sido de grande
importância especialmente devido às
consequências potenciais que podem
ocorrer em certas populações então o
ponto crítico que nós precisamos abordar
é a síndrome pós
moléstia então mesmo após o vírus ter
sido eliminado do corpo muitas pessoas
relatam sintomas persistentes esses
sintomas incluem fadiga fraqueza
muscular dificuldades respiratórias
entre vários outros então estudos
recentes como que foi realizado na
Universidade Federal do Rio Grande do
Sul identificaram mais de 26 sintomas
associados ao pós moléstia então isso
sugere que a Resposta imune exagerada
durante a infecção pode continuar a
impactar o corpo resultando em
complicações de longo prazo incluindo
imuno
trombose então concluindo a imunr é uma
resposta do nosso corpo que em condições
normais ajuda a combater infecções é a
trombose ajudando o sistema imune a
eliminar infecções no entanto em doenças
graves como a moléstia esse processo
pode sair de controle ficar
descontrolado levando a complicações
potencialmente fatais então é
fundamental continuar estudando essa
relação especialmente com o avanço das
terapias gênicas que eles vão empurrar
mais para nós no futuro vocês podem
esperar isso então com esse avanço das
terapias gênicas gerem a
mensageiro nós temos que estudar isso
cada vez mais para entender melhor como
que Essas tecnologias podem influenciar
a Resposta imune e seus riscos
Associados então se você achou esse tema
interessante compartilhe esse vídeo com
seus amigos e familiares
na verdade peça para eles assinarem a
parte fechada do canal né convide a eles
para fazer parte da nossa comunidade e
deixe seu comentário agora durante a
Live pra gente poder ver se você tem
alguma dúvida sobre esse assunto
Ok tem uma pergunta aqui da
Eliane ele troços alterados na urina é
um sinal de infecção ou pode ser uma
alteração momentânea
Nem sempre a infecção Eliane pode ser é
uma inflamação no rim uma aglomera no
nefrite por bactéria ou pode ser uma
aglomer nefrite por doença autoimune né
que chama de
eh aglomer nefrite por exemplo pós
infecciosa né que dá em algumas
situações que doença autoimune e pode
ser por cálculo também pedra nozin Então
são as causas mais comuns cisto renal
também pode dar isso
daí Doutor ainda em relação ao uso da
Ivete na diabetes existe exe algum dado
relativo ao impacto na doença por
exemplo reduz Glicemia de jejum gente
não tem estudo ainda Clínico entendam
isso isso é muito novo estudo que tem em
cobaia o estudo que tem em vitro em
cobaia entendeu não temos estudos em
seres humanos ainda é muito novo
isso ok então hoje tá me perguntando
seria uma informação clínica nós não
temos essa informação Clínica ainda
mais dúvidas
pessoal de nada
Fernando que mais pessoal vamos
lá o Eliseu não tá online hoje só deixou
a dúvida
também tá bem diferente
né Deixa eu olhar aqui no no pessoal que
tá
WhatsApp Ah o Eliseu tava ele colocou
aqui por mim aia para amanhã pois é
acabei não adiando O Eliseu
é por isso que tem pouca Pergunta hoje
né porque eliz não tá
online Não podia participar nesse
horário bem acho que eu vou encerrar né
taquinha Fernando miram Eliane são vocês
quatro que estão ao vivo né Alguém tem
dúvida de vocês
Obrigado Fernando pelo comentário fechou
Beleza então então vou encerrar tá
pessoal hoje vai ficar mais curta mesmo
a
Live pessoal Se vocês quiser qu usar IV
como antidiabético como
anti-inflamatório como anticâncer
como imunomodulador ou como antiviral
todas as cinco funções novas dela tá só
sendo estudada em vitro e cobaia
eh tem que acenar um tempo de
consentimento informado para usar
isso digamos assim para essas situações
tá bom
pessoal bem obrigado a vocês uma boa
noite até a semana que vem beijo no
coração